we're told 10 000 Russians are coming
through this Crossing every day not so
many at the moment it's quiet and down a
bit but the more striking scenes are on
the other side of the crossing there
down that narrow Gorge there are
thousands of Russians crammed in and
they've been waiting there for hours
trying to get through that border
crossing and then snaking away from
there for 10 kilometers is a traffic jam
of cars most people Park in the cars are
getting out and walking and they're
dealing with a very difficult uh
temperature extremes it's extremely cold
because we're so high up here when the
sun is not on you when it when it is on
you it's it's pretty hot they're also
dealing with these rumors these reports
that the Russians as you say are going
to put a mobilize mobilization Center
into that building intercepting Russian
men who uh should be facing call up on
this mobilization order by Vladimir
Putin and then packing them off to
Ukraine uh to fight there also they're
dealing with these rumors that the
border crossing is going to be closed
soon so it's a it's a panicky mood over
there we were told by some of the people
who've crossed we met one man who um has
got a got over in time he received his
call-up orders and he said he didn't
want to be become meat for Vladimir
Putin to be thrown into the war in
Ukraine a lot of other people are just
trying to get out they say because
they've had enough of living in Putin's
Russia a hundred at least a hundred
thousand Russians have crossed here
probably more like 120 130 000 the same
kind of number into Kazakhstan we've
seen a lot getting out into Mongolia and
also into Finland so Russians in their
tens of thousands are voting with their
feet in response to Panama Putin's
mobilization plan and that's posing I
think big problems for him but also for
Russia there's a brain drain underway
we've we've met people here from
Engineers to I.T Specialists even a
nuclear physicist and they are just
walking out of Russia and I think a lot
of the people were seeing are younger
there the more more college educated
they're better qualified they're the
people who could be called up or in
danger being called up and being sent
off to fight so they're leaving Russia
and that's a problem for Russia for
years to come there's the risk of social
unrest we've seen in Dagestan and places
processed against the police by people
who feel they could be called up we've
seen these dramatic pictures of of these
protesters kickboxing policemen and
head-butting them that's the strength of
feeling and we've seen very brave people
going out and protesting across the
streets but I think the big problem for
poosing is that this new Army he's
trying to gather is it seems extremely
demoralized unwilling to fight already
judging by the people we're talking here
and that we're seeing trying to flee
Russia in their tens of thousands and
what Army and history has ever beaten a
motivated well-armed Army if it's
demoralized itself and so that I think
is the problem for the the military
logic behind Putin he's trying to
generate this new Army but it's not
going to be the kind of army that could
Prevail against Ukraine it seems Russia
is looking increasingly unlikely to win
this war but that's not putting Putin
off sending thousands more men into
battle and for many of them their
certain death or injury